you do think about is it selfish is it
worth it is it something
[Music]
so
um
Sir Richard Branson Richard Branson is
one of the most fun-loving and
adventurous billionaires in the world
he's conquered our scars blasted off
into space the entrepreneurs
entrepreneur the marketers marketer in
the School of Business they said focus
by the age of 33 you've got 50 different
companies you kind of break that law it
seems if we'd stayed still and only
focused on one business we wouldn't have
a business today if we were still going
strong 55 years later if you get the
little details right makes for an
exceptional company over an average
company we were the first airline to
introduce seat back videos in the world
sleeper seats for business class
passengers we've always been ahead of
the pack the airline's been bullied by
British Airways famously through the
dirty tricks campaign
the best always succeeds as if all of
that you've done before wasn't enough
you decided to aim for the Stars we're
going to space looking back at this
beautiful beautiful Earth that we live
on the whilst floating it was a dream
come true you know we're still at the
early stage of space travel and there's
still risks One Pilot has died after a
passenger spaceship crashed everything
that we'd built up looked like it was
crashing down what impact does that have
on you and your mission
you've got to continue
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
Richard having spent the last
24 hours reading both your
autobiographies but also your new HBO
docu-series
Eve your mother
um she she felt like a really really
extraordinarily principled and
um strong character and in the
docu-series you actually say that you
didn't realize how much she had
influenced you on becoming the
entrepreneur you are today
what was it that she was doing pushing
her out the car at 45 years old and
making you walk home but what is what
were those principles that underlined
her approach
so I mean she was one of the sort of uh
first entrepreneurs around really I mean
not you know not a particularly
successful one but she was
um making table mats and you know
cutting out pretty pictures from books
and making and and
turning him to you know turning them
into uh pictures that she would then
take to Harrods or
um Harvey Nichols
um interestingly and I didn't realize
this until I sort of saw it in some
letters that she'd written to me
um uh
um you know working from a phone box in
in London
um and um
uh and that was her office just like my
office had been later on working from a
phone box at school
um but um uh yeah but so she she would
never stop she she was an idea idea a
minute and always trying to uh uh you
know better better Our Lives better and
um
um and also always trying to create
things that she could be proud of when
was she most proud of you
in terms of what kind of behaviors or
achievements would make her most happy
when you're young
um
she
um
yeah she was she was fairly
uh yeah she was she was fairly firm when
it came to you know the need for
um you know being courteous from a young
age and I mean I remember
uh uh in church one day I refused to go
and sit next to some somebody that she
wanted me to sit next to who was maybe
visiting our house
and and when I got home
um uh she asked my dad to spank me and
uh that that had never happened before
and my dad takes me into
the living room into into the next door
room and um uh and and instructs me to
burst into tears and he slaps his hands
together very hard six times I come out
rubbing my bum
um but um
um and then of course she regretted
having done it in the first place but of
course it never happened so
um the um but um
um but that you know that you know she
she you know she generally speaking it
was
um unreserved love but she she wanted us
to uh care for other people properly
um you know if we ever said ill about
somebody would be sent to the mirror and
uh we'd have to stand there for 10
minutes
um because it you know she felt it
reflected so badly on us uh that we'd
said ill as somebody
um and you know those sort of less
lessons I think were very very very
powerful and very good uh later on in
life when I was you know leading people
um always trying to look for the best in
in everybody
one of the threads throughout your story
which um shocked me surprised me and
inspired me in many ways throughout the
docu series was this continual desire to
move on to the next thing and make
things bigger and to capture another
opportunity which struck me as being at
times like really defining character of
you you know even when things seem to be
successful by anyone's estimation you
pushed on again and then you'd push on
again and again do you have any idea
where that instinct or that
characteristic came from in you I'm sure
that came from um uh my mum I am Son of
Eve which which is my mum's name
um and um
but it's also I think because I was
dyslexic
um and you know pretty hopeless at
school
um I've forever been trying to prove
something to myself
um and
um and and
proved something that you know when she
was alive to her and my dad
um and um
uh I'm inquisitive I just love I love
learning about new things
um uh and once I've actually absorbed
everything there is to know about you
know the uh the thing I've just created
a map app to want to move on and learn
learn something about something
completely different
um particularly if I feel other people
are not doing it well and and I just
love diving in there and and um
uh trying to you know shake up an
industry that is badly run do you think
she she and your father even your father
um Ted
had high hopes for you
I think that
um my mum uh definitely thought that I
would be and
yeah she she she
decided that I was going to be prime
minister of uh Britain one day and um uh
and I think that um yeah she so she she
definitely had high hopes for me
um uh my dad just wanted uh us to be
happy I mean he was a very uh love
lovable content
and funny uh witty uh individual
um wanted to be an archaeologist but
ended up uh going into the law after
after the war and would have been happy
I think what as long as we were happy he
didn't mind you know he didn't really
want to push us but
um but my mum I think expected expected
more of us you mentioned School a few
moments ago
you and me both have a similarity in
that we were hopeless in school you went
off to boarding school at seven years
old which in and of itself is a pretty
extreme experience for a seven-year-old
you describe this as being a little bit
too young in your view
um and you struggled
in part because of your dyslexia
at the time did you did you know what
dyslexia was or what it meant
no I had no idea what dyslexia was I
just
um assumed that I must be a little bit
thick
um I mean I could just about add up and
subtract but when it got to more
complicated stuff like algebra and
geometry and the likes I couldn't
understand the reason for it I wasn't
interested in it you know I couldn't
understand why we were having to learn
French when when nobody seemed to ever
actually speak it when they left school
and
um or Latin or
um and um and so I suppose in my head I
rebelled against
um
being taught things that I couldn't see
the relevance of
um and um and actually that was a good
thing because it it it ended with me
rebelling from actually staying at
school and leaving school at 15
um and uh and creating
some uh and creating a magazine uh which
um to try to sort of address some of the
issues in the world
your dyslexia um you've often
highlighted that in many respects it's
been a superpower it's given you skills
that have led to your success what what
is that what are those skills and what
is the advantage in your view of this
dyslexia and how that's changed how you
function operate
um I think
uh that um well first of all I I would
like to say I'm proud of being a
dyslexic thinker
um and I I'm delighted that uh dyslexic
thinking is now becoming
um almost part of the vocabulary
um
um and I'm pleased to you know talk to
many dyslexic kids over the years to try
to make them realize that
um you know you know do not do not be
worried about it
um you know look at look at the areas
that you
um that you enjoy and con concentrate on
those
um and the areas that you're not great
at
um you uh you know either that you'll
catch up later on in life
um or you know if you're going to start
a business you can delegate and find
other people who can deal with those
um so I think dyslexic
dyslexic people
really excel at the things that things
that there that interest them
and I think I know a lot of a lot of
business people for instance who were
dyslexics who've
um who uh have have
um Gone Gone on to do incredible things
your Headmaster
um I read the very uh slightly humorous
slightly um shocking story of uh when
you're at boarding school you had a
little bit of a romantic run-in with his
his daughter Charlotte got expelled uh
staged to fake suicide got unexpelled
um and then you as you referenced a
second ago you had this idea for the
student magazine I read that there was a
an ultimatum given to bioheadmaster
where he said Richard I know you're
starting this magazine you're either got
to leave school or um and start the
magazine or stay in school and focus on
your formal education and at that point
you made the decision to jump ship
yeah I mean I I don't think the
Headmaster was very foresighted I think
uh you know if a kid at school wants to
start a national magazine for young
people what a great education and that
they should have they should have
welcomed us to stay at school and do it
you know within the from from school uh
but the Headmaster wasn't going to allow
me to do that
um and and thank God because
um you know getting out into the real
world I achieved a lot more than I would
have done um if he'd uh if if he'd been
Pleasanton said uh you know run the
magazine from school
um there were a lot there was a lot
going on in the world
um
you know there was the Vietnamese War
um there was the biafran war and there
were
um uh the Provost in Holland there was
um uh uh it was the education system
that needed students to rebel against
and
um and the and so it was a it was an
exciting time in the 60s to leave school
go to London
um and try to start a magazine I watched
your um as I watched your docu Series
yesterday in that that theater
um that we're all in including yourself
one of the lines really struck with
struck me when when they showed the
small room that you were building this
magazine in I know sometimes it was a
post box but sometimes there was a small
room I think at a later date a line was
said which was um
this was my education
and for young people who are considering
take taking a leap when they have very
little responsibility or think you know
very little to lose throwing themselves
in that kind of throwing themselves in a
situation where they'll fail their way
to an education
struck me as being so important and so
underrated you don't have kids or you
don't have a house or a mortgage and it
seems like that's exactly what you did
you used like failure and
risk as a way to self-educate
yeah I mean
it's difficult for me to recommend it to
everybody listening to this program
because not everyone's going to be
successful and obviously you and I have
been fortunate that we we have had
success doing it that way
um some people are not going to get put
my conservative hat on knowing that the
parents may be listening as well
um you know some people will benefit
from having an education you know degree
or whatever to fall back on if the if
they're if they're they find that
they're they just can't make a go of it
in business
um
but anyway for I I think for the two of
us
um I think the um uh yeah being out in
the real world I mean I learned so much
um and uh
um and it you know it's held me into
such good stead throughout my life
um you know in running a magazine of
course you know you're going out
interviewing people you're learning
every time you interview somebody
um I I you know I think um being a
journalist or being being an editor you
um is not so different from being an
entrepreneur you're you're out all the
time meeting new people in different
sectors just learning learning learning
um and
um and you know through the magazine
uh a lot of people would write with
problems
um young people would write with
problems so we ended up setting up as a
student advisory Center uh where we
would um
uh give people advice on venereal
disease or gay people the gay population
or
um or
um you know contraceptive advice
abortion advice
um psychiatric advice
um you know and and you know just
meeting all these people with all these
different problems suicidal
so a societal mental problems
um really open open my mind it was just
a fascinating fascinating education and
um and throughout my life since then
I've spent a lot of my life trying to uh
address some of these issues in a in a
first of all in a wider sense in London
and now more more on a global scale and
um but but that was you know that is
education of um was so important
um you know for instance I remember when
I
was 15 in London you know somebody who's
gay came to me saying that they wanted
help and um maybe I just turned 16 and
um
and I thought very naively that when
they said they wanted help that you know
they didn't want to be gay and of course
you know within a month or two I
realized that you know that people are
born gay and uh and uh and they don't
have a choice in the matter and and what
they what they desperately need needed
in those days was to meet other gay
people and uh because it because if they
came from
um some remote place in the UK where gay
people weren't accepted
um they would come to London Desperately
Seeking seeking love or seeking
friendship
um and um uh and and so you know just
little things like that
um I learned from
um just just being out there listening
and doing
you're that was that magazine was your
um the first sort of big notable thing
that you you've done in business and
throughout your story and even before I
I'd met you and watched the docuseries
and read the book I was told by other
people Richard Branson's a super an
amazing delegator you mentioned it
earlier on your your delegation skills
to understand how to delegate to someone
else you first as you've said need to
understand your strengths and weaknesses
and also their strengths and weaknesses
so what is what are your strengths in
your own words what is the bit of the
puzzle that you're good at
I think I'm good with people
um I think
uh I try I can trust people I think I
can surround myself with
um uh you know with with with really
really good people I think I'm
uh able to
um uh yeah to delegate to delegate not
to second second guess them all the time
um
uh yeah to pray he's not criticize
um and um
uh and
uh I I think I'm I think I'm quite good
at uh if I create something making sure
it's the best you know the best in its
area
um so that the people who are working
for Virgin are really proud of what
they're doing
um
uh you know it's really important that
um
you know if if if somebody's in a pub
and they work for Virgin and somebody
says what do you do that they're they're
proud of the fact that that you know
they work for Virgin and they're happy
to say it and there are some companies
that that
um if people work for they weren't they
weren't really want to be able to say
that they work for such and such a
company
um
yes I think I I think I think the
people's skills
um is is is the is the most important
um
skill
um I think um
uh just giving giving you know giving
things a try
um uh you know screw it let's do it
obviously it's one a phrase I made did
years ago and and uh and I've used that
phrase many many a time you know
somebody comes with a
an idea and I like them and
um and and yeah just say and you know
let's let's give it a go and um and
sometimes we both we all flat full fat
in our face sometimes sometimes it
succeeds
and conversely then what are the what
are the weaknesses that you've kind of
observed in yourself or the things that
you tend to delegate to other people
um I actually read something which said
which is a quote of yours that said I
wanted like an IQ test at eight years
old I don't think I filled in anything
going forward 30 or so years I was
running Europe's largest private group
of companies but I didn't know the
difference between gross and net profit
but it didn't matter
yes I was in a board meeting uh
when I was about 50 years old and
and the director
um
said um and I think I said is that good
news or bad news and then and one of the
directors said come come outside Rich at
a minute so came outside and he said you
don't know the difference between that
and gross to you so I said uh no
um uh he said I thought not anyway I
brought a sheet of paper so she brings
out the sheet of paper and the uh he's
he has some color pens and he colors it
in blue and then he puts a fishing mess
in the
um in it and then he puts a little fish
in the fishing net and he says then
so the fish that are in the net that's
your profit at the end of the year and
the rest of the ocean that's your gross
turnover
and um I went oh got it and I was ever
ever since then I've been name dropping
that engross to people who've obviously
know full well what it is and
um but but the point of the story is
uh it really doesn't matter
um I mean it's bet it's a good idea most
likely if you're
you're
chief accountant uh knows
um uh but you know for a for somebody
who's running a company
what matters is can you
um you know can you create the best
um the best company in its sector you
know if you're gonna
create an airline
is it going to be palpably better than
um the Rival Airline if you create a
cruise company is it going to be
probably better than the other Cruise
companies if you're a great trained
company is it going to be probably
better than what's gone before and if it
is then at the end of the year it's
likely that more money that will come in
than goes out
um and um uh and then somebody you know
somebody else can add up add up the
figures
um
uh so I think you know to be to to run a
to run a business you know yes it helps
start up it helps to subtract
it helps to multiply
um I don't even think you need to worry
about division
um that that's it so
um uh you know so if you can if you can
do those three things
um uh you can run a business if you
can't do those three things I wouldn't
worry too much you'd find somebody else
you can and just but just go out and
create something that's going to make a
positive difference to other people's
lives
that student magazine became um kind of
pivoted at the end into a mail-order
music business which is a big part of
the docu series that we watched
yesterday
um but then it became so many more
things and it's the interesting thing is
kind of how you Swang from one of these
business ideas to the next because you'd
seen a product or service that you
thought could be done better or there
was an opportunity there when I you know
in the School of Entrepreneurship if
that's like a metaphorical thing we
always talk about the importance of
focus
now when I look at your story from 15
years old starting that magazine to
starting a mail order business around I
think 20 22 years old when Virgin was
kind of um conceptualized and launched
and then by the age of 33 you've got 50
different companies involving everything
from film making to
um conditioner cleaning and generating
more than 10 million dollars in sales
I go this is not what they told me about
the need for focus in the School of
Business they said Focus you kind of
break that law it seems a focus
so
um
uh so I've I've never really thought of
myself as a business person
um uh obviously you know on paper I am
an entrepreneur
um or a business person
um uh I've never really been interested
in the bottom line despite uh what the
uh the the doc docq series seems to
betray
um I I really have been interested in
creating things I can be proud of
um and uh and a lot of those things come
out of personal frustration and I must
be frustrated quite a lot when I was
young because and and ended up you know
trying a lot of things
um uh and
um and I just found it great fun
um investing and you know people I met
um you know you know somebody will come
along and uh you know the the music
business may have been
um you know struggling at one stage in
my career with Within Advent of the iPod
and and you know a couple of guys come
along and say
um you know we you should do mobile
phones this is you know this would
replace the music business and yeah and
they were great great people and and and
you know so we thought screw it you know
let's do it let's get you to go into the
mobile phone business and and and so if
we if we'd stayed still and only done
only focused on one business
um
uh maybe let's say the record business
um let's say record stores which is one
of our earlier earlier things
[Music]
um
uh we most like we wouldn't have a
business today because the you know Mega
stores and Roads and and record stores
no longer exist because
um the the iPod and free music really
put them out of business
um and so you know so by actually going
against the rule rules of you know what
you learn in business school
um we you know we we're still going
strong you know 55 years later
um
and um uh and diversification actually
saved us I mean like you know during
covid
um uh you know Virgin Atlantic and uh
very badly hit uh companies uh was was
saved by virgin I mean being able to
celebrate Galactic shares so
um so diversification
um is far more exciting
um you learn a hell of a lot more and it
can be useful in times of crisis
clear that only a great delegator would
would be able to diversify without
creating spreading themselves too thinly
per se I'm not sure I guess that goes
back to that skill of diversity of
Delegation
your Headmaster said something to you
that my best friend urijway said to me
when I was 18 years old after I dropped
out of University my best friend Joe
Ridgeway um from Plymouth said to me I
remember I stood in this this Curry shop
on uh on in rush home he said you're
either going to be a millionaire or in
prison
now when I read that this morning when I
was doing research on um your Headmaster
it stopped me and my breakfast halfway
through my sort of chew I thought gosh
now I know why he said that to me
because he knew there was a certain
level of desperation in me and there was
a certain craftiness which was could
either take me could either be used for
good or evil
when you was when you did the student
magazine
that that
um prophecy appeared to come true one
day when the police raided your magazine
and arrested you and I learned about
this in the docu-series last night
your your mother then puts her house on
the line to get you out of jail and you
choose to expand you you choose to
expand your way out of the problem which
for you men as it said in the docu
series opening 30 record stores that
year to be able to pay your mother back
have you always chosen to expand your
way out of problems
um
yes I think I think the answer is yes
um I mean I I spent one night in prison
in those days you had to pay tax on
records if you ship them to Europe
sadly with brexit you're going to have
people gonna have to do that again but
um uh and um
and I stumbled into the fact that if you
drove across the channel and drove back
again you had a piece of paper which
said you'd exported the records and
therefore you didn't have to pay the tax
and
um and um uh but uh anyway so we we we
we we we we got her a a a bad rap on the
knuckles I spent I spent a night in
prison and swore never ever ever to
spend a second night in prison in my
life
um and uh and yes we expanded fast in
order to pay pay off the fine
um uh we just needed the turnover
um and it was it was actually um uh
actually a really
um uh a a wonderful booster to to all
the team at virgin to to and uh and um
uh and fortunately you know we managed
within three years to pay to pay it off
um but um
I mean I it sometimes we're expanding
uh uh expanding just for the
pleasure of learning about something new
and um and then maybe occasionally on
like like on that occasion we're
expanding to get ourselves out of pro
out of trouble
quick one this episode is brought to you
by Mercedes-Benz who recently got in
touch to support the driver CEO I'm
becoming quite the fan of electric cars
and of course a huge fan of
Mercedes-Benz I have one of my own the
Mercedes-Benz luxury electric range
known as Mercedes EQ is it the very
Forefront of this industry which is what
really stood out to me if you're looking
for a business car the sustainability
credentials economic benefits General
convenience and high levels of luxury
which everybody knows Mercedes-Benz 4
and they're all electric cars are truly
groundbreaking in terms of features
their next Generation technology across
the range is second to none for example
there's intuitive mbux technology with
AI that learns your behavior and keeps
you connected to the things that matter
to you not to mention all Mercedes EQ
cars offer exemption from the ultra low
emission Zone charge and London
congestion charge so if like me you're
really excited about all things electric
cars and if you haven't checked out the
Mercedes EQ range then search
Mercedes-Benz Fleet to see how they can
take your business to the next level
quick word from one of our sponsors you
must be living under a rock if you've
not heard about wework but I think in
the modern world where people are
working remotely on the go they're
entrepreneurs building their businesses
wework has never been more important
than it is right now there are some
incredible things wework have released
to enable entrepreneurs like you like me
to be able to work flexibly comfortably
with the resources Wi-Fi and everything
else the infrastructure we need in
hundreds of locations around the world
and one of those things is called wework
All Access where if you have all access
wework you can work in hundreds of
different locations as you travel around
the world and as you move around the
world and as you go to meetings around
the world we work for entrepreneurs in
my opinion is a total Game Changer and
to encourage you to check we work out if
you've never worked in one before I'm
offering 50 off a one day booking if you
go to we.com
CEO and use the promo code diary check
it out I love wework and they've been
great partners and supporters of this
podcast
the most from my perspective one of the
most
um terrifying decisions you ever made
was to go into the airline industry
Warren Buffett's fairly famous for
saying that he has once considered
employing someone to sit in his office
and every time he feels like investing
in an airline to talk him out of it
because it's such a absurd terrifying
business to get into
you were running a very successful
record label and record store
um business by then you had many many
companies many Investments and you
decided to take this huge bet to start
an airline
now there's a lot said about why
could you tell me in your own words why
um it it really was out of frustration
of
um flying on other people's Airlines
having having bad experiences and and
feeling that
um we could uh we could do it better we
could make it it could be more fun I
mean in in
those days uh you know if you flew on
saber's shareways it was a monopoly
um uh they you know you were you you
maybe got a lump of chicken dumped in
your lap
um there was no entertainment
um the cabin crew certainly didn't enjoy
working for the company and and and you
really felt like you're just being
herded from A to B in in a cattle truck
um and um
uh and so uh I flew I was flying all
over the world
um to um
uh to uh to visit our record companies
because we had record companies for most
countries around the world and and just
felt you know we could we could do it
better and
uh somebody came along to us with the
idea of a business Airline
um only I didn't think that would be
very exciting to run
um and um but I thought a really really
good quality Airline for everybody
including business people
um you know it would be a a something
special to run and um uh and so ended up
ringing up Boeing and
um and having a wonderful discussion
with a wonderful guy called RJ Wilson
and ending up and being able to uh lease
a secondhand 747 from him
um
and um and because you know uh I do like
to you know to protect the downside
which is obviously important in business
and I did a deal with him where I could
hand the plane back at the end of 12
months if you know if my instinct was
not right
um and um but fortunately at the end of
12 months people love flying on Virgin
Atlantic and we ended up you know
getting a second and a third plane from
Boeing and and that was yeah 38 years
ago and
um and
you know Virgin Atlantic has um
uh you know it's like a uh it's roughly
the same age as my daughter
um uh you know um she's been the
airline's been bullied
um by British Airways I mean famously
through the dirty tricks campaign
um uh it was a really tough time
um we took ba to court and we won the
biggest lipo damages in history
um
uh uh she's had she's had to go through
the like think crashes like the um uh
911 disaster
um the 2008 disaster and it's the covid
disaster
um and uh and I'm sure that we've it you
know that it's cost us more money than
um than we've ever made from it
um uh but it's been the flagship you
know for Virgin
um it's enabled us to launch other
companies in different countries around
the world and the back of the the strong
brand and the strong reputation it's had
um and uh she's she's a a daughter that
I will zealously protect and and
um uh as long as I can when you look
back at why that business survived
considering the first competition
considering what British Airways did and
what ultimately found guilty of in court
with their dirty tricks campaigns the
bit that really stuck out to me
yesterday was hearing that they had a
staff member hack into your customer
database
um to kind of see spy on what you were
doing that went to court you won the
battle
um and that acted as a real boost I
think for Virgin because it kind of
staged you as this sort of David versus
Goliath
um situation where you were the underdog
but as you look back on that Journey
many people have fallen in that industry
it's a graveyard as you say in the
documentary why did virgin win what was
it was it brand was it customer
experience was it just Grit
I think I think that
[Music]
um
I think a lot comes back to staff I mean
um that we we've always had a great
um team of people working at virgin
they're they're really proud of the
company
um uh
um they um
uh we've done things you know we've
always been ahead of the head of the
pack in in new Innovations so
um you know seat back videos for
instance we were the first airline to
introduce seat back videos in the world
um uh the um uh you know sleeper seats
for business class passengers
um uh
um you know stand-up bars and
um and lounges and so on um you know
collect collecting money at the door you
know um for charity that virgin was the
first to do that and how pretty will
every Airline and most airports are
doing it as well this change
um so I think
um uh you know every little detail I
think we
um the team have got right at virgin
um and um
uh and if you get the little details
right you know um then collectively
um uh you it makes for an exceptional
company over an average company and
you know if I'm on a virgin play and
I'll I'll or in any version company I'll
have my notebook I'll take notes I'll
listen to it listen to the staff listen
to the customers
um you know and then act on it when I
get to the far end and um
uh and and then being back in touch with
the people who gave me the ideas to
thank them and tell them what we've done
and and I think a good a good leader has
to be a good listener
um and if you're if you're um
uh uh and that's I think one of the most
important attributes of a good leader
I grabbed my phone halfway through
watching the docq Series yesterday when
you mentioned the seat back videos
because in the same breath you mentioned
how every accountant would tell you
um not to do many of the things that
you've chosen to do but also the banks
wouldn't even lend you the money to do
the seat back videos they'll give you
the money to like two billion dollars to
do the planes but they wouldn't give you
the 10 million to do the seat back
videos you've mentioned Instinct as well
a few times
as a CEO over the years I've had this
battle between like instinct and the CFO
you seem to tend to I think the quote
you said was
um you tend not to consult Finance
people and accounts people when you when
you have these ideas
how have you found that battle between
the two between your instinct and your
vision and the money people going
this won't work this doesn't make sense
I suspect that you're not you're the
entrepreneur and and they're the CFO
because you're the entrepreneur and
they're the CFO so I think you just got
to believe in your your your your
instinct and
um and um uh and and go with it and if
you create something you know I mean
we're just opening a new hotel in uh New
York
um you know if it's the best hotel in
New York even if it's gone over budget
in in the building of it which it which
it will have done
um uh the the best always succeeds
um uh you know we we
famously during covid uh launched a new
Cruise Line virgin voyages
um uh you know it is
you know so much better than any other
Cruise Line out there
um you know we've had two years where
we've had to multiple the ships
um but you know we're stuck with it
because we know that the quality is such
that
um people will seek it out and and uh
and the feedback's been you know
spectacular I mean it's virgin at virgin
and its absolute best
um I'm actually heading there this
afternoon
um you know it's fascinating each ship
has
78 different nationalities working on it
you know 1200 people and they're just
the best and and it's adults only and
it's a lot of fun and and
uh but you know there were moments
during covid that we did think you know
we definitely chosen the wrong business
to launch virgin at its absolute best
what does that mean what is Virgin at
its best
virgin at its best is when you launch a
new company and you know that because
you know people have experienced
previous virgin companies
um that they will give it a try you
don't really have to even advertise
um they they know that when they went on
a version train uh when we ran the
network that it was you know really good
quality when they went on a virgin plane
it was great quality when they went in
diversion Health Club it was good
quality
um and so on
um and um so you know that that gives us
a big Advantage with with the brand that
that people have tried they've loved
um and so when we launched something new
like a cruise line they will give it a
go and and we make sure that we don't
let them down and and and and and then
you know having them try the cruise line
if we decide to do a new Venture
um you know week at week it's that much
easier for us to launch it off off the
back of the cruise line
you you are so synonymous with the the
Virgin I don't think I know a person who
is as synonymous with their brand as an
individual so when you think of Virgin
you think of Richard Branson we think of
Richard Branson you think virgin
um and in 1985 you start doing some
pretty extreme
Adventures around the world which become
kind of pay into the brand and give give
the brand extra meaning things like
crossing crossing the Atlantic by boat
which sunk uh it seems like a lot of the
uh the trips you took either collapse
like fell out the sky into the into the
the sea or the boat sank um you set so
many records through that period
um so you know I was reading about you
going 250 miles per hour in a hot air
balloon
across the the Pacific from Japan to the
Arctic in Canada again breaking um
existing records at the time this became
a real Hallmark of like the the Richard
Branson and virgin brand these Extreme
Adventures was that intentional when you
did that first one did you was was it
because of a marketing thing or was it
because of the fun of doing it for
yourself
it started out uh uh as
a mixture of the two but more uh we had
one plane
um and somebody said you know why don't
we try to bring the Blue Ribbon back to
Britain for the fastest boat across the
Atlantic
um and you know we could we can we can
build this boat
um and um uh but it ended up being much
more than just a marketing Adventure it
became it became a real Adventure I mean
it was you know tremendously exciting
and
um I was in in my
very early 30s and and
um uh and you know it was tough but it
was it was great fun
um there were you know lots of um
moments of drama uh which there always
are when you're trying something that's
never really been tried before
um including as you pointed out we sang
we sat before we got the whole way
across
um uh but um uh but anyway it makes for
a good documentary series
um and it makes for a good book and and
and and
um and you know and it did put virgin on
the map it made virgin a much more
sexy brand a more adventurous brand than
say
British Airways arrival
um uh and and other another and other
brands
um uh I mean Virgin Atlantic cheekily
took a full page ad when we
when we when we sank in the Atlantic the
only thing that was sticking out of the
Atlantic of the boat was um the brand
virgin and
um and the ad just had the picture of
the boat sticking out of the water and
and the ad said next time Richard take
the plane
and and of course there were people who
said you know what have you seen what if
you end up in the in the Atlantic you
you know no one's going to want to fly
an airline where and but of course it's
quite the reverse it's it you know
people
uh you know it helped put it helped put
a tiny little Airline on the map and uh
more effectively than anything else we
could do and much more cheaply you
mentioned that ad from um from your
competitor there
in the moment competition is the arch
enemy you know causing you a ton of
nuisance but as you look back on the
competition you've had throughout the
different Industries you've been in has
the competition actually made you
stronger and better
at what you've done
yes and I think the reverse is also true
and that that uh you know these big
public companies or big government-run
companies like British Airways have been
made the better
um by having
um Virgin Atlantic innovating and you
know them having to you know catch us up
over the years and I think British
Airways is a better company today than
it was
um you know uh 38 years ago when we
started so competition's good for all of
us
um big big and small and
um and the only role that governments
need to play is intervening when there's
unfair competition
um and that's one of the most important
roles the government can play
um is um uh uh is making sure that they
set laws that encourage competition and
don't stifle competition and
uh and you know we've had uh yeah anyway
there have been books written about
um uh about companies that have tried to
stifle virgin in the past but
um somehow we somehow we came through
there's this time now called personal
branding which is become very popular
predominantly because of social media
and everybody having a channel and they
can build followers and they can try and
tell the world who their company is
using social media but you were kind of
the first
CEO personal brand to many people
because everything you did
added value to the brand and it wasn't
just what virgin said I think when I
look at your story it teaches me that
the brand is what what the people do and
what the founder does becomes the brand
more so than ever
um
and I think that's often what we lose
sight of and some of the best brands in
the world like the Red Bulls of the
world have figured out that the things
you do say much more about the brand
than what you say yeah and you are like
the perfect example of that in the early
90s you got in a bit of a struggle
because of the broader economy and you
ended up selling your record business
from all accounts and from speaking to
some of your current team they said that
this was a very difficult moment for you
that it was crushing I think the quote
that I that I was told um
is that accurate and why was it why was
it crushing
oh look I think uh
um
if you think of your if you think of the
um
uh the things that you create like
children which
um which I I do and and I'd think of it
like that because it is just a bunch of
people
um and I mean you know your business is
yourself and a group of people
um if you sell it it's light selling
selling you know if you sell a company
it's like selling a group of children
and and that's um that's tough all round
um I needed to uh I needed a war chest
to combat British Airways and and and
and the dirty tricks that they were
um uh they'd launched at virgin and
um and you know so you know the war
chest
um that that I thought I could best tap
into was Virgin Records
um
the good thing was that you know the the
staff at Virgin Records
you know still had a had a job but um
working for another company and the
staff at Virgin Atlantic were safe
because we had the financial clout to
um to deal to deal with our competitor
um so there are you know there are
obviously times in life where you have
to make tough decisions like that and
um uh and uh and yeah but it and move
and move on do you have any regrets
about about how that happened by that
phase
um I have I I always think that if if
anybody asks me if I ever have any
regrets about anything it would be I'd
be a very sad person to answer you
answered positively because you know
I've had the most extraordinary life
um it's been full of you know
interesting twists and turns
um
uh and I honestly really you can't think
of anything I regret you know in the
past
[Music]
um
they um and I think I really do think
I'd be a sad person if I if I had
regrets I mean it's just been uh
uh rich with Rich with um uh you know
adventure and uh and and people and and
and and I'm not somebody who looks back
and by and large I mean obviously an
interview like this I will but
um uh and I suppose I've reached an age
where
you know it's important to write books
and it's important to do documentaries
and you know because it's important not
to waste your life and and and and it's
important to share what you've learned
how did you feel yesterday watching the
um docu series on your life
I was sat just behind you so I'd watch
I'd look at the screen and I'd look at
your reaction and I'd see you laughing
sometimes
um
I was emotionally drained to be honest
um I I mean after the after party and I
just could not really get my what my
words out for the first half an hour
um uh it you know I found it quite you
know fairly exhausting
um I mean they've it's incredible uh a
really good documentary maker and Chris
Smith is one of the best in the world I
mean you know Prides himself on on his
independence which I respect completely
and and so we you know we didn't have
input into it
um you know obviously therefore not
everything one's going to agree with and
and not everything is you know in in my
brain would be exactly as as it was but
you know 95 96 was was was as I see it
and but but but just what is is
incredible was the archive footage they
managed to find
um you know considering we'd had my main
house but went down and my main house
blown down in a hurricane
twice
the fact that anything survived to be
able to make such a you know such a
really full quite you know really quite
exciting I think
um document documentary series was um
you know I have to take my hat off to
them
and then in the uh as I watched the last
episode of the docu-series last night I
saw you once again in typical Richard
Branson style set yourself a new
frontier which was space
as if you you know as if all of that
you'd done before wasn't enough you
decided to aim for the Stars
why
um
so I remember
um many many many years ago
um when President Gorbachev was um
uh leader of Russia and he was trying to
bring peristoca and bear a striker
to
the west and trying to
put out peace signs
um he invited me to come to Russia to be
the first person to go up in a Russian
spaceship
um but it would have meant a big check
um you know 60 million it would have
meant um a year
um learning Russian and being in Russia
and I just didn't have the time that uh
and already the spare money to do
something like that but it did just get
me thinking
um you know that's an inordinate amount
of money to charge for somebody to go to
space you know for that kind of money
but we why why couldn't they just build
start building a spaceship
um and um and so we registered Virgin
Galactic Airways and um
and I was set up where it went around
the world trying to see if we could find
somebody to build us a spaceship and um
and then just found this genius but
return you know to me
um you know I've I've always dreamed of
going to space one day
um I think uh 50 of the people listening
to this program will will have will have
dreamed or will dream of going to space
50 will think you know why why on Earth
would you want to do that
um but
um you know it's it was the most
extraordinary Day of My Life
um the my my trip to space and
uh and uh and you know looking back at
this beautiful beautiful Earth that we
live on it was um uh from space whilst
it was floating uh
um at the you know whilst floating with
a lovely group of people
um uh just an extraordinary
um experience and um
uh and to be honest yeah to pinch pinch
you pinch oneself moment to be doing it
in a spaceship that we that we built and
uh
um and um
uh and uh yeah so it was a dream come
true
in that documentary we're also reminded
of the the cost of all of these
Endeavors at a moment when there's a
shot of you taking a phone call at your
house learning that in the lead up to
um virgin galactics going to space for
the first time
an astronaut had died in one of the
tests it's a very emotional scene but it
is a reminder of of
um the cost of these great Endeavors to
humanity
that day when you receive that phone
call and then you you rushed yourself to
the to the to the site
what's on your mind
so it's happened to me twice in my life
um uh
you know I was once in a cinema in um
uh in Europe uh with my kids and I my
phone just kept
kept vibrating and and and I ignored it
and ignored it and then on the sort of
third or fourth time I decided to walk
out of the cinema and check it
um and one of our trains had come off
um the track and um uh and you know
straight away I knew that you know um I
just had to get to the scene of the
accident and and
you know there were no flights that
night so we had to had to drive through
the through the night
um and then yeah and and uh and then
anyway we got got there
um early early in the morning the next
day
one lady had died and you know and I
um went went to the morgue to meet the
relatives and
um you know we we had a hug hug and um
uh and
um I mean fortunately it turned out it
wasn't actually a virgin's fault but
um you know but you're still obviously
responsible for um the fact that it was
on a virgin train
um and
um and uh and then you've got to as
owner
um you know confront talk to the press
and and and and but it it I think the
fact that you make the fact that you
make an effort and get get there quickly
uh is very important and and the same
when when when we
lost a test spaceship
I knew straight away based on my
previous experience with the train that
I needed to be there as fast as possible
is there a conversation about
discontinuing Virgin Galactic at that
moment after losing that life yeah there
was I mean you know we I sat down with
George Whiteside and just said you know
is it you know asked our sales questions
is it worth it is it worth um
you know is it worth continuing what
what what would happen if we had a
second accident
um uh you know we would never never be
forgiven I mean it would you know it
would
um our reputations would be destroyed
um
um uh
um but then we then we spoke with all
the all the engineers and um we spoke
with many of the people who'd signed up
to go to space and and we spoke with the
family and
um of
um uh of the pilot who who'd lost and
with one with one voice they said you
know you just gotta you've got to
continue
um uh and um
uh and we did and and uh we're still you
know we're still
um you know we're still at the early
stage of space travel and there's still
risks I mean we think that
um you know we don't
um you know we think that we're through
all the big risks
you know we've got to we can
automatically switch off
an engine if you know if anything's what
goes wrong with the rocket motor just
and and we've got we've got astronauts
actually flying flying our Craft
um but it is the it is it is the early
stages and um but
um but I think everybody everybody
involved are doing it with their eyes
open
one of the most um beautiful
heart-wrenching scenes from the ducky
series is in 2021 when you are months
away from your first space flight on
your on your own
spaceship spacecraft space plane
whatever the terminology is
um
you've named it after your mother you've
named the mothership after Eve
and then tragically
um she passes away from covid
before she has the chance to embark on
that space journey with you which she
was planning to do
that phase of your life when you lose
your mother when you lose Eve
what impact does that have on you and
your mission
and it it I mean first of all she'd
lived a a long life and an extraordinary
life and and so it was
um uh yeah uh and I mean you know I was
very very fortunate in our family were
very fortunate to have had her around so
long
um and um uh and the absolute last thing
that she would have wanted was for for
um for the mission or any missions to be
held up
um as a result of her death I mean you
know she she will uh you know if there's
a star up there
um she'll be on it and and I'm sure that
she was there and uh there in spirit
when
um when when I went to space and she
definitely would have been smiling
smiling down and down down at us with
with my dad Ted
um and um uh so uh yeah and so I think
when we when we lose loved ones we it's
you know we you you live on you live on
through your parents and you know and
your children live on through you and
and your grandchildren live on through
your your children and uh and you know
that's the sort of Wonder the wonders of
life and when you came down from that
space flight
um which is detailed in your your second
memoir in the sort of updated version
which has just been updated
you wrote a letter to your mum after
coming down from space you said dear mum
you always told me to reach for the
stars well I took my own winding road
but I always knew when to follow your
lead you always pushed us to our limits
you were always a dreamer you urged me
to strive for every opportunity I saw
you told me to Chase my wildest
fantasies to live life to the full how
you lived how you loved and how you are
missed
yeah I mean she um
you know I think uh
uh yeah hopefully
um yeah when when people read the book
they'll think about their own their own
mums and dads and and and and you know
how how lucky lucky we are to have mums
and dads who sacrifice so much for us
and um and as as we're as we as we grow
up and then obviously later on in life
um one can what you could one can give
you know give give back and
um looking after them as they get a
little bit older
the docu series was a bit of a punch in
the face from the start because that
because of that opening scene about your
family where
you're sat there ahead of your journey
to space trying to say some words to
Holly Sam and Joan your wonderful wife
and your kids
just in case you never make it back from
space this is something that you've done
time and time again before you embarked
on these Journeys
um
really really difficult to watch really
difficult to watch
um and took me by by surprise because it
was so early on in the film
why why was why is it so hard to to get
those words out otherwise you seem like
such a composed individual but when it
came to those words
it seemed like you know multiple takes
you got up you walked away you came back
got it walked away and came back
so
um
so first of all I I do uh
um I cried in happy films I cry on sad
films my kids bring a box of tissues
when we when we go to the cinema or used
to
um and uh so that that
as I am
um uh you know even even now just
talking to you I can feel tears my eyes
so
um so um uh so it is it's not surprising
for me to suddenly uh not not be able to
get my get through my sentence sometimes
um but obviously look if you if you're
uh if you're
reading
um if you're if you're if you're
speaking about as if you as if you've
died to
um you know to to your kids and your
grandkids and yeah lots of emotions go
for your head at the time of saying of
speaking I I suspect even the emotions
of my God should I be you should you
know is it is it worth it and a lot a
lot of the this documentary series is
asking the question is it selfish is it
worth it is it uh is it is it is it is
it something
um uh is it is it something that um one
should be doing
um
I remember
um
I was in I was just taking off on
to go across the Pacific in a hot air
balloon and walking into this truck and
um
Jen third Kettle from ITN was just
finishing editing my obituary
um in case I didn't come back
and she said you know Richard do you
want to sit and
watch the obituary
um and I said why not and um and you
know I sat and watched the obituary and
again had a couple of tears in my eyes
at the end of it but
um but
um you know but I do think that in life
well you know one advantage of doing
these Adventures is actually you do
confront the ultimate inevitability of
of
um you know that you're not going to be
here forever and so you do think about
uh you know have I left everything in
order
um you know what am I going to say to my
children what am I going to say to my
grandchildren a lot of people don't have
that opportunity because they they die
suddenly so
um you know it's so I have written quite
a few letters over the years uh in
thinking that I just may not come back
from this adventure or that Adventure
the documentary also shine a light on
Joan who has clearly been this huge Rock
in your life over the years she's a
strong tenacious
um
honest very uh very to the point
wonderful woman
what does she mean to you and what has
she meant to you over the last
40 50 years oh
um well I was lucky enough to meet her
45 years ago in a recording studio
um uh called The Manor uh walked into
the kitchen and just looked across the
room and she was the most uh gorgeous
creature I'd ever seen in my life and it
was in instantaneous love from me to her
and it took me a while the other way
around but she's just a fantastic down
to earth glass region
um doesn't suffer fools gladly
um
complete opposite to me
um you know it doesn't play tennis
doesn't uh run doesn't uh ski doesn't
climb mountains
um you know it doesn't go adventuring
but you know she's the most fantastic
mother for Holly and Sam and the
grandkids
um and um
uh and she knows what matters in life
um so you know I mean the the uh in in
the end I suppose what matters is
you know the love you can give to your
children
um uh the food on the table and
uh
um yeah but or above everything just
unreserved love
um to to all everybody around her and
and and
uh and everything else is
um
uh is sort of icing on the cake
you're a man synonymous with living a
life worth living one of the quotes from
the film was about you know not living a
life
um that is full of risk is not living at
all words to that effect if I was Sam or
Holly your kids and I asked you I said
Dad what's um what is a life worth
living
what what would you say to me
I think just to for to first of all
fulfill their own fulfill their own
dreams I mean I mean not not to have
their father or
mother push them into things they don't
want to do so
um you know I was lucky with my my
daughter wanted to be a doctor and she
she did the medic she became a doctor
she now helps this with our foundation
um my son
um wanted to make films and and
uh and he's a musician basically which
is his main love and he and he does a
little bit of both of those things
um they're both fantastic parents and
they find the time for the grandkids
um so I think just to
um you know to follow to follow whatever
dream it is that you have as best you
can
um and um
uh and yeah and you know we've been
lucky that our kids have kids have um
I think found that found their path in
life
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last last guest asks a
question for the next guest not knowing
who they are asking it for
um the question that has been left for
you is
where were you
when you when you felt most vulnerable
and why
I think I felt most vulnerable
um relatively recently
um during the
uh
about six weeks into covid
um when
uh everything everything that we'd built
up uh looked like it was crashing down
um
uh and uh and interestingly when uh the
sort of British press rather than being
supported have really really turned on
us
um
uh and uh and but fortunately you know
my kids and grandkids and everybody
arrived
um
um around about that same time and uh
and the team just got down and worked
really hard day and night to make sure
we kept as many jobs safe as as possible
and um uh and uh and I think pretty well
every version company got through it and
pretty well every every employee jobs
got protected
um but but that was that was maybe the
toughest time in
um toughest time in my life for you know
suddenly it just looked like one for
your reputation and everything else was
going out of the window but covid was
tough for so many people and um
um but um yeah but but um we've we've
held it to
Holly and several members of your team
reference that as being
um your toughest moment
but the word tough is just a word if I
Zoomed In And if I was there what would
have and I was you what would I have
seen and what would I have felt when you
say the word tough well I think I I
think that um I I've never understood uh
depression
um uh and I and I think I understood
it's like you know that where people get
depression from after that experience
um and it was good you know it's good to
under you know it's good to have gone
through it myself a bit I mean it didn't
last too long
um because I've you know
brought up by you know parents who've
you know been through the second world
war and you couldn't waste your time you
know getting depressed you know they're
much far worse things than being
depressed
um but anyway it it took it taught me to
understand it which I think will
hopefully make me better understand
other people's depression in the years
to come what were the symptoms of that
ah
what were the symptoms of it that's very
difficult to to pinpoint the symptoms
but you know look you just you just feel
very sorry for yourself for a day or two
and then you just have to snap out of it
and and and get you know my mum my mum
would have if she'd been alive and what
she was but I mean if I talked to her
about it she would have told me to pull
myself together and just and and and get
back to work and uh and um and I think
within two or three days
you know her her words would have been
ringing in my head and and I would have
um overcome it and I did overcome it but
it just you know you just did a taste of
it anyway
Richard so Richard Branson thank you so
much for your time
um I you to me you've when I started
this podcast you were the name you were
the name that if one day I could speak
to on this podcast I think we might as
well pack it up and finish because to me
as a entrepreneur my whole life you've
always been the north star of
entrepreneurs you've represented and
embodied what it is to be a entrepreneur
that's striving for to create better in
everything you do I had the pleasure of
researching your story again now at 30
years old and it's been a tremendous
source of inspiration for me
um to meet you today to get to come and
watch your docu-series is one of the
highlights of my entire entrepreneurial
career and life and definitely this
podcast so thank you so much for that
because I'm I'm not sure you'll ever
really appreciate how much of an impact
you have on people like me
um so I want to make sure that all I
have you here I have a chance to tell
you and to thank you for that because
you've definitely changed my life and
um I know I'm not the only person um so
thank you your book is amazing the
docu-series was so captivating I stayed
up till about 3am and last night making
sure I watched all of it and then
watched it the last episode again this
morning and I implore everybody to go
and check it out now on HBO
um but yeah the most important thing is
I just wanted to say thank you well
thank you back and and yeah many many
congratulations on all you've achieved
and all all and being a young bastard
or you will achieve in the years to come
thank you Richard
quick one from our longest standing
sponsor hero I I can't tell you over the
last I'd say over the last really it's
been about two and a half years it was
really um post pandemic how much my
health has become such a huge priority
in my life and I have this laser laser
focused on what I'm putting into my body
it's funny because as you get older you
can start to feel the things you're
putting into your body more and more and
more
um and if I if I put something into my
body especially things like gluten if I
put those things in my body I feel them
tremendously the next day my energy
levels my sleep and everything in
between huel has been probably the most
important partner in my health Journey
because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and I trust it most of my
team that are in this room with me
consume it and get the benefits of it
too so if you haven't already tried your
do so until now one of our sponsors on
this podcast and I'm here to tell you
about their vpro platform security and
data protection are totally
non-negotiable when it comes to the
technology I use for my businesses I'm
constantly thinking about where we can
upgrade our systems to protect against
potential threats so this is where Intel
V pro has become our go-to Intel V Pro
is built for businesses it has a
hardware-based multi-layer platform
security features protecting from cyber
attacks threat detection and also
recovery systems all in one platform in
an Ever challenging cyber landscape if I
can put measures in place that I believe
will save me time and money that I
absolutely will so head over to
intel.co.ukvpro to find out how it could
work for your business
[Music]
thank you